♪ ♪ ♪
- À un peu moins d'une heure
de route au nord d'Edmonton,
la raffinerie Shell de Scotford
ressemble à toutes les autres
en Alberta.
Mais ici, depuis 2015,
la multinationale utilise
la technologie de captation et
d'enfouissement du carbone pour
une partie de sa production.
Tous les ans à la raffinerie,
c'est un million de tonnes
de CO2 qui sont captées, soit le
tiers de toutes les émissions.
Pour l'industrie pétrolière,
c'est à ça que ressemble
l'avenir. À l'aide de filtres,
le carbone est retenu à la
source, puis concentré sous
forme liquide, avant d'être
réutilisé ou enfoui dans le sol.
Une fois sous terre, le carbone
est censé y rester de façon
permanente. Capable de retenir
jusqu'à 90 % des émissions,
la captation du carbone est
devenue un des sujets de l'heure
dans l'industrie pétrolière.
Grâce à cette technologie,
l'industrie espère pouvoir
continuer à augmenter
sa production tout en réduisant
l'énorme empreinte carbone
des sables bitumineux.
(en anglais)
Le président de l'association
canadienne des producteurs
pétroliers considère
la captation du carbone
comme un outil important, même
s'il admet qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'une solution miracle.
L'engouement pour la captation
du carbone ne se limite pas
aux pétrolières. Le gouvernement
canadien y voit aussi
un grand intérêt.
Dans son dernier budget,
le gouvernement fédéral investit
319 millions de dollars dans
la recherche et le développement
de la technologie, une somme
importante, mais loin encore
des 30 milliards que réclame
le gouvernement Kenney à Ottawa
au cours de la prochaine
décennie, pour en accélérer
l'application.
Aussi prometteuse soit-elle,
la captation du carbone
demeure pour l'instant très
coûteuse et les gouvernements
doivent massivement
subventionner son utilisation
comme ici, à Scotford.
Même si le prix de la tonne
de CO2 au Canada va passer
de 50 $ en 2022 à 170 $ en 2030,
la captation du carbone
ne sera toujours pas rentable
à court terme.
- Vos objectifs de
carboneutralité, est-ce que
c'est vraiment à n'importe
quel coût?
- Ce qui fait dire à l'Institut
de l'énergie Trottier dans
un récent rapport que
la captation du CO2 devrait être
réservée à des secteurs comme
l'agriculture, qui ont plus
de mal à réduire leurs émissions
à la source.
SIMON LANGLOIS-BERTRAND, cherch.
Institut de l'énergie Trottier
- On ne peut pas se mettre
à parier sur le captage dans
tous les secteurs où on a des
émissions. À un moment donné,
ça fait une très, très grande
quantité d'émissions à stocker
chaque année par la suite.
- Pour atteindre
la carboneutralité, les
gouvernements devraient miser
davantage sur d'autres
solutions, croit le chercheur.
- La majorité des
investissements devraient être
faits pour être capables
de réduire les émissions.
- Sauf que dans une province
profondément dépendante
du pétrole, la captation
du carbone est vue comme
une planche de salut.
Si à elle seule elle
ne réglera pas tous les défis
environnementaux de l'Alberta,
la captation pourrait toutefois
permettre une transition
énergétique moins difficile
pour la province